[Música]
bernardine evaristo es la primera
escritora negra en ganar el prestigioso
premio booker en 2019 junto con la
canadiense margaret atwood por su libro
niña mujer otras traducido a 41 idiomas
la autora británico nigeriana cuenta hoy
con ocho novelas y libros de poesía que
exploran diversos aspectos de la
diáspora africana también activista y
defensora incondicional de la inclusión
de artistas y escritores de color Bernal
y nevaristoa puesto en marcha a varios
proyectos para garantizar una mayor
representación en las Industrias
creativas dialogamos con ella sobre la
traducción al español de su primera
novela raíces rubias una fábula que
recrea con sutiles hay humor la trata
transatlántica de esclavos con esta
inversión de los colores de la historia
evaristo Nos invita a desmontar y
denunciar los mecanismos de dominación
que actúan en nuestras sociedades
Gracias por acompañarnos en trans24
ganaste el premio booker en 2019 y ahora
nos encontramos en el Ay festival de
Cartagena en 2023 Cómo ha cambiado tu
vida desde que ganaste este premio tan
prestigioso
cambio Más allá de lo que podía imaginar
lo gané después de 40 años en el mundo
de las artes pero todo en mi carrera
cambió de la noche a la mañana
de repente empecé a tener un público
enorme mi libro se tradujo a 40 idiomas
me dieron un grado de respeto y
notoriedad que no había tenido antes y
estoy de gira por todo el mundo desde
hace tiempo ha sido una experiencia
realmente maravillosa totalmente
positiva
y te invitaron aquí en este festival en
Colombia para hablar de en español de tu
primer libro de ficción raíces rubias
publicado en inglés en 2008 si no me
equivoco
Tal vez sí
es la historia de un mundo alternativo
donde los europeos son los esclavos y
los africanos son los amos de dónde
surgió esta idea esta nueva forma de
tratar el tema de la esclavitud
quería escribir sobre la trata
transatlántica de esclavos porque fue
una parte importante de la historia del
mundo durante cientos de años pero
siempre me gusta hacer las cosas de otra
manera no quería escribir la típica
historia de esclavos Así que pensé
durante mucho tiempo cómo podía
abordarlo de manera que hiciera algo
diferente con la historia Entonces se me
ocurrió la idea de crear un mundo en el
que los africanos esclavizaran a los
europeos y eso me entusiasmó no sabía
cómo iba a funcionar Así que fue un poco
de experimento no sabía cómo iba a
funcionar Así que fue un poco un
experimento pero cuando empecé a
escribirlo me di cuenta de que podía
bastante satírico Y también que el mundo
que cree era un universo paralelo Así
que no era realista podía jugar con él
podía jugar con las ideas y al mismo
tiempo seguir explorando el tema de la
esclavitud
pero nunca temiste que este libro
pudiera ser utilizado por ejemplo como
argumento para quienes creen que existe
el racismo contra los blancos que esta
dinámica de dominación podría invertirse
o se está invirtiendo actualmente en
algunas partes del mundo
creo que cuando escribes algo así en lo
que te arriesgas siempre existe la
posibilidad de que la gente se lo tome
mal pero creo que cualquiera que lea el
libro entenderá que estoy escribiendo
sobre la experiencia de los Esclavos
negros y que lo verán tal y como es
hubo gente que dijo sobre el libro que
hubo blancos que fueron esclavizados por
Norte africanos en algún momento de la
historia y yo dije sí vale es verdad
pero fue una trata de esclavos muy
pequeña sin embargo eso no niega el
hecho de que hubo 400 años de trata
transatlántica de esclavos Así que en
realidad no escucho a los críticos de mi
cabeza que me dicen que no debería hacer
algo ni a los críticos de fuera que me
dicen que no debería haberlo hecho en
general la respuesta al libro fue muy
positiva Así que mis temores se
disiparon
quería hablar contigo sobre cómo el
público recibió el libro ya que lo
escribiste en 2008 y ahora que tenemos
la traducción al español y que también
hay una nueva edición que salió en
febrero en Francia Durante este lapso de
tiempo como ha evolucionado la respuesta
a este libro en particular
No lo sé no me llegan las reseñas de las
ediciones extranjeras porque están en
otros idiomas Así que nunca sé cómo
están siendo recibidos los libros
pero no tienes por ejemplo lectores que
te escriban o cuando hablas con la gente
quiero decir lo hago de vez en cuando
por ejemplo lectores alemanes se ponen
en contacto conmigo pero no lectores
españoles
puede que ocurra
tal vez
También quería saber Aunque fuese
bastante tiempo cuando analizabas y
luego invertías todos los códigos y
normas que vemos en las revistas en la
tele en internet códigos de vestimenta
de belleza de lujo de deseo también fue
una experiencia difícil para ti porque
como lectores aunque seamos conscientes
de estas normas de estos estándares casi
siempre occidentales leer raíces rubias
es bastante duro a veces
para mí no fue duro No de hecho me
divertí mucho porque jugaba con las
nociones de salvajismo y civilización
como usted dice todas las normas las
normas de la Europa Blanca se vuelven al
revés de modo que las normas africanas
se convierten en las normas aceptables
Así que Fue divertido pero también hay
una tragedia en el libro porque trata de
la tragedia de la trata de esclavos
trans atlántica y tuve que cargar
emocionalmente con eso
cuando describía lo que llamamos El Paso
intermedio la captura de africanos que
en mi libro son ingleses y el viaje a
través del Atlántico hacinados como
sardinas no había lugar para el
humory
es algo muy serio y trágico Y como
escritora me siento emocionada con esas
partes del libro que estoy escribiendo
Pero sí Definitivamente hay un elemento
lúdico que para mí es la parte divertida
pero incluso al revés describes los
cánones de belleza como difíciles de
alcanzar y violentos y el estilo de vida
y los hábitos de la élite económica como
perjudiciales para ellos mismos Cuál es
la moraleja de esta historia
no sé si hay una única moraleja creo que
cuando se crea una sociedad tan tóxica
tan desequilibrada tan cruel no solo
sufren las víctimas de esa sociedad sino
también las personas que la perpetúan
porque están siendo dañados cíclicamente
por sus propias acciones
Creo que este es uno de los temas del
libro que estoy explorando en cuanto a
la moraleja me gustaría dejársela al
lector para Que decida si se alinea
moralmente con lo que ocurre la novela
[Música]
hablabas de lo mucho que te divertiste
escribiendo el libro y que utilizaste el
humor Incluso en los momentos más
oscuros del libro y es verdad lo que me
ha encantado de esta novela es como
juegas con las palabras y también como
juegas con lo que tu personaje principal
piensa en su cabeza es algo importante
para ti cuando escribes Mostrar la luz
Incluso en el momento en el que no la
hay
creo que tiene que haber ambas cosas
tiene que haber luz y oscuridad Y eso es
algo que recorre ese libro y que recorre
toda mi obra no soy el tipo de persona
que escribe un libro deprimente porque
quiero que la gente tenga Esperanza
Quiero explorar los placeres de la vida
así como algunos de los elementos más
difíciles Así que siempre compagino
ambas cosas Nunca es puramente
desenfadado porque sería superficial Así
que es una mezcla de los dos
en tus obras seguimos la vida de
personajes intentan encontrar su lugar
en una sociedad racista homofoa sexista
ahora en la vida real pones de tu parte
para cambiar eso cofinanciaste la
primera compañía de teatro de mujeres
negras en el Reino Unido trabajaste en
un programa de mentores para poetas de
color creaste un premio internacional de
policía africana crees que la sociedad
está cambiando poco a poco
creo que he visto muchos cambios la
sociedad que yo conocí cuando era una
joven veinteañera no se parecen nada la
que vivimos hoy en Gran Bretaña creo que
hemos progresado que nos hemos
convertido en una sociedad mucho más
inclusiva y progresista
Pero obviamente siempre hay mucho más
espacio para el cambio tenemos un largo
camino por recorrer creo que es muy
positivo saber que si haces campaña si
presionas las cosas empiezan a cambiar
Si aceptas el statu quo tal y como es
nada cambia porque el statu quo no tiene
ninguna intención de cambiar nada porque
funciona para ellos pero si estás fuera
y crees en el cambio social Tienes que
luchar por él y es realmente alentador
pensar que esas luchas empiezan a
cambiar la sociedad desde dentro y eso
es lo que está ocurriendo en mi país
tuvo muchas gracias